no but that photo the the meme was seen
everywhere that we showed and 22 did you
know that that it went it went around I
had no idea my kids showed me like I
didn't know what was going on it was it
was ridiculous but I was happy think
people were thinking of me that's all
you have literally there are so many
memes of it do you have a favorite that
you that you've seen there were a couple
that made me laugh really hard uh there
was one with like I had like a bow cut
uh and I don't remember what it said but
it just it just made me laugh it had all
the chains around my neck we had a bow
cut so right there yeah it it just it
got me um but there were there were tons
of them they just and it didn't stop you
know it's funny it was it was it was
ridiculous we need to laugh yeah we do
the shot ever and speaking of that is
there ever going to be a reboot of King
of Queens people are doing reboots I'm
just saying it's I'm just saying I I
don't think we can man because yeah we
got Jerry Jerry Stiller was was so part
of that show I would not want to do it
without him he yeah it's such a huge
show in pop culture I think people are
just like ohic oh I miss him he's
amazing it's amazing to work with a
great cast that you click they were the
greatest Leah is incredible and uh
lovely yeah yeah so it was it was so
much fun to do and such a great time in
my life and it was like you know I get
to see it still it's on so people you
know still come up to me now younger
generation that's the thing with
streaming now people are seeing it for
the first time it's like well this is
older but yes it's brand new for you I
guess yeah yeah I had hair I I know but
you actually look pretty badass yeah
like I was good I was thinking that we
walked out I was like no this is it this
is a look this is a Vibe okay it's got
to be God God made it that way
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home